[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
je m'appelle
je pense que la vie est une vaste blague
mais c'est pas si grave en fait quand on
y pense et même plutôt une bonne chose
c'est de ça dont je vais vous parler ce
soir je vais essayer de vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est intéressant de commencer
des projets très sérieux à partir de
blague
j'ai découvert ça il ya une dizaine
d'années à l'époque j'avais un groupe de
heavy metal qui était d'assez mauvais
goût et dans mon pays natal l'ardèche il
y avait un concours de musique organisé
chaque année et chaque année mon groupe
se faisait refusé à la sélection et un
jour avec mes amis on s'est réuni on
s'est dit pourquoi est ce qu'on ferait
pas une blague cette année pourquoi
est-ce qu'on enverrait pas un faux
groupe
alors c'est ce qu'on a fait on a composé
de fausse chanson on a trouvé un faux
nom électronique bistoufly ce qui ne
veut rien dire
on a écrit une fausse biographie parce
que quand vous avez 18 20 ans ben quand
on vous demande ce que vous avez fait
dans votre vie ben à peu près rien donc
on a expliqué qu'on était très célèbre
dans les années 70 que notre chanteur
était mort d'une overdose qu'on s'était
fait cryogénisé pour réapparaître
quarante ans plus tard pour sauver le
rock'n'roll le site bizarre que ça
puisse paraître cette année là on a été
sélectionné
on a gagné le tremplin on a rencontré un
producteur on a sorti un album fait 200
concerts on est devenus découvertes du
printemps de bourges
il ya des blagues qui peuvent durer très
longtemps
avec le recul je pense que ce qui s'est
passé c'est comme en transformant notre
projet en blague ou en jeu de rôle
en fait on s'est émancipé nos propres
contraintes mentale et paradoxalement on
s'est mis à faire ce qu'on aimait
vraiment et à partir de là c'était très
facile de travailler sérieusement et
difficilement pour développer le projet
aujourd'hui ce projet est terminé
j'ai repris mes études après sam et j'ai
essayé de répliquer cette même approche
dans tous les projets que j'ai menée par
la suite et je vais vous en présenter un
ce soir je vais vous expliquer comment
je suis en train d'essayer de reproduire
la même approche sur quelque chose de
nouveau
c'est un projet qui se déroule en trois
temps est en fait en trois blagues
la première blague j'ai étudié en donc
dans un programme de gestion de
l'innovation et je navigue dans
l'univers des hackaton vous connaissez
les hackaton c'est les événements où
pendant trois jours une grande
entreprise vous demande de travailler
gratuitement pour elle sur un projet qui
est censé sauver le monde
on a fait une blague on a voulu faire l'
inverse comme d'habitude et on a demandé
aux gens de créer des innovations qui
pourraient potentiellement détruire la
planète asservir l'humanité et conquérir
l'univers
on s'est retrouvé avec une centaine de
projets chose assez triviale comme cette
couche culotte électrique qui donne des
décharges électriques aux enfants qui
auraient le malheur de faire leurs
besoins s'était imaginé par une mère de
famille qui avait des enfants en bas âge
et des choses un peu plus inattendus
comme cette ville imaginée par un couple
de personnes âgées dans laquelle tous
les trottoirs et les escaliers serait
surélevé de deux mètres pour qu'il n'ait
plus accès à rien c'était une blague à
la base c'était bizarre d'avoir des
projets comme ça en fait je crois que ce
qui s'est passé c'est que les personnes
ont fait la même chose que nous avec
notre groupe c'est à dire que derrière
le jeu de rôle elles sont mises à part
les deux bas de leur vraie souffrance en
fait et c'était assez touchant est assez
inattendue en mai j'ai appris autre
chose ce jour là quelqu'un est venu me
voir en me disant essai du design
fiction ce que tu es en train de faire
je connaissais pas le mot vous savez le
design c'est une discipline qui a pour
but de régler des problèmes ou de
répondre à des besoins
il ya une notion fonctionnel dans le
design la plupart du temps pas là
là l'idée ce n'est pas de résoudre des
problèmes c'est d'en causer encore plus
l'idée en fait c'est de créer des biens
des objets services qui seraient en fait
des objets support de débat et de
réflexion
ça c'était la première blague la
deuxième elle n'est pas de moi c'est
plus une blague de la vie je travaille
au sein de la direction d'un gros groupe
et je surprends indice une discussion
entre deux personnes très haute dans la
hiérarchie qui sont en train de parler
d'un projet qui va bouleverser
totalement le monde et son train de
parler de ça 2 mitoyen je sais pas si
vous voyez très bien en fait c'est un
écran qui fait la taille d'un muret qui
permet à deux appartements d
relié et d'après eux ce projet va
complètement bouleverser le business de
l'immobilier et le business de
l'assurance immobilière
je me rends compte deux semaines plus
tard qu'en fait c'était un projet de
design fiction imaginée par un designer
qui s'appelle max mollon qui a écrit une
thèse sur le sujet est en fête qui a
complètement échappé à son créateur
parce que maintenant on trouve ça sur
internet et on ne sait plus distinguer
le vrai du faux tout ça c'est pour ça
que c'était une blague de la vie pour
moi ce qui est intéressant c'est que cet
outil qui pouvaient d'une part canalisé
des souffrances et des frustrations
pouvait également être un outil pour
influencer des influenceurs j'avais
devant moi des décideurs des gens qui en
réel budget dans une grande entreprise
et qu'ils peuvent concrètement changer
le monde et ce truc là pouvaient les
influences et c'était assez amusant
c'était la deuxième blague
la troisième blague j'ai terminé mes
études je sais pas quoi faire comme
métier je suis spécialiste de tout un
tas de choses mais expert en quasiment
rien et il faut que je crée ma carte de
visite
sauf que je sais pas quoi écrire dessus
jusqu'à ce que je tombe sur un livre
très bizarre écrit par alexandro
jodorowsky j'ai pas si vous le
connaissez c'est un artiste surréaliste
qui a notamment réalisé la montagne du
sacré la série de bandes dessinées
l'incal avec nos bus et qui est surtout
célèbre pour ne pas avoir réalisé le
film d'une c'est à dire que c'est le
réalisateur qui n'a pas réalisé le film
en réaliser le plus célèbre de
l'histoire du cinéma et dans son livre
un peu bizarre manuel de psychologie
nous invite à créer des cartes de visite
qui porterait le nom de notre métier
imaginaire pour glisser dans notre poche
et nous soulager l'esprit alors c'est ce
que j'ai fait je suis scénariste de
prophétie auto réalisatrice
ça soulage et mon esprit j'ai pas
forcément trouvé de travail
il ya très peu d'entreprises en fait qui
embauchent des scénaristes de prophétie
auto réalisatrice
s'il y en a dans la salle où si vous en
connaissez je suis preneur
et puis en discutant avec un de mes
camarades avec qui nous avions organisé
notre foi caton on s'est dit mais est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas relier ces deux
choses ces deux premières blagues en
fait canaliser des souffrances et créer
des objets sous forme de canular qui
pourrait influencer les influenceurs et
je me suis dit bas quitte à avoir un
faux métier autant avoir une fausse
entreprise et au verso de la carte de
visite il ya cette mention la celles
entreprises que j'ai créées almanac
c'est un design think tank
c'était un think tank populaire donc il
canalise des souffrances et qui crée des
objets par le design fiction et la
science fiction diffusée sous forme de
canular pour influencer les influenceurs
est ce que vous savez ce qu'on a fait
avec cette blague on a fait des dizaines
et des dizaines de blague
on a notamment créé ce faux rapports
internes de l'entreprise renault qui
aurait fuité du service design c'est un
rapport qui travaillent sur le
pragmatisme et la rationalité des
algorithmes qui nous dirigent
aujourd'hui ce rapport répond au fameux
dilemme de la voiture autonome vous
savez est ce qu'une voiture autonome
doit écrasé un piéton pour sauver un
passager il répond oui mais ça dépend de
la nationalité de la personne
parce qu'en fait en politique publique
on peut estimer l'impact de la dépense
d'une politique publique donc on peut en
fait estimer la valeur d'une vie humaine
sauf que cette valeur est en fait indexé
sur le pib du pays d'origine de la
personne on peut être qu'un jour un
algorithme va nous dire ah oui on peut
écraser un chinois si c'est pour sauver
un danois mais pas l'un vers ce vous
avez compris ce que je veux dire c'est
pas une critique
on a créé un autre projet que j'aime
beaucoup c'est le universal singularity
order cela est un groupe terroriste
on a travaillé sur le rapport entre
religion et intelligence artificielle
eux leur but c'est de créer des micro
robot tueur connectés à internet cash et
partout sur terre pour que le jour où
une intelligence artificielle forte
débarquent sur terre et puisse prendre
contrôle de ces robots et assassiner les
personnes qui ont empêché son avènement
d'après ce groupe terroriste ça pourrait
créer une pression qui pourrait
accélérer l'avènement de l'intelligence
artificielle
on a poussé la blague un peu plus loin
avec ça parce qu'on on a lancé des
processus de recrutement sur linked in
c'est pas une très bonne idée devrait
faire du recrutement pour un groupe
terroriste
il ya aussi des mauvaises blagues on
nous a fait beaucoup et en ce moment on
est en discussion avec un départements
de la région rhône alpes pour travailler
sur le rapport que les jeunes
entretiennent avec le travail non monde
rural ce qu'on voudrait faire dans ses
ateliers avec des jeunes s'est imaginé
un village dans lequel tout le monde est
revenu universel pour arriver à
déterminer quels seraient les
propositions électorales du maire du
village et est diffusé en fait ses
promesses de campagne dans la presse
locale pendant les prochaines
municipales
alors jusqu'où cette blague va aller
cette fois j'en ai pas la moindre idée
est en fait c'est pas vraiment ça
l'important
l'important c'est que je sais pourquoi
je le fais parce que ça me fait rire je
sais aussi que j'ai cette carte de
visite dans la poche et que ça m'a un
jour conduit à faire ce tête devant vous
ce qui n'est déjà pas si mal
je suis pas en train de vous dire il
faut transformer les métiers le travail
en jeu je sais pas si vous avez déjà vu
des salles de réunions notamment dans
nombre de l'innovation c'est rempli de
pâte à modeler et de briques de lego
c'est assez infantilisant en fait je
pense que c'est même un peu dangereux je
vous conseillerais pas travailler de
transformer votre travail en jeu
je vous dirais plutôt l inverse trouver
quelque chose qui vous fait vraiment
rire et faites-le très sérieusement je
vous dis pas non plus de faire du design
fiction même si persuadé que c'est un
outil extrêmement pertinent et
performant pour comprendre notre époque
notamment notre rapport à l'innovation
c'est un outil très performant également
pour communiquer je dirais de trouver ce
qui vous fait rire vous parce que si une
blague vous fait rire c'est qu'elle a du
sens pour vous et si elle a du sens pour
vous le projet qui en découlera on aura
tout autant
merci
[Applaudissements]